(triumphant music)
(flag flapping)
(The Star Spangled Banner)
(The Star Spangled Banner continues)
(flag flapping)
- Yale has a proud
tradition of involvement in
and ties to military service.
Many of us have walked by
the statue of Nathan Hale,
who sacrificed his life for his country
in the Revolutionary War.
And we have read the
cenotaph on the quadrangle
that honors the hundreds of Yale students
and alumni who died in World War I.
Through our shared history,
the Yale community is
connected to thousands
of Yalies who served in the First
and Second World Wars, Korea, and Vietnam.
This connection extends to
the faculty, students, staff,
and alumni who serve today.
The spirit of service and sacrifice
that link our military personnel
is a hallmark of Yale's mission.
Our university is characterized
by a deep commitment
to the common good and to the security
and prosperity of generations to come.
In these turbulent times,
I am more grateful than
ever for all those who work
to strengthen the fabric
of our university,
of our country, and of
communities around the globe.
I appreciate deeply our faculty, staff,
and alumni who are veterans.
Yale is committed to
supporting our veterans
through programs like the
Yale Veterans Network,
a campus group of students,
faculty, and staff.
And the Yale Veterans Association,
an alumni organization.
And Yale is proud of its
students who currently serve
in the Reserve Officers
Training Corps on campus.
The COVID-19 pandemic has
shown us how necessary it is
that two great institutions
of American society,
its universities and its
professional armed services
are here to educate future leaders
in how to handle the trials
and uncertainties in life.
As we mark Veteran's Day,
it is vitally important for us
to remember the human toll of war.
Individuals have made
and continue to make
extraordinary sacrifices
in service to this country.
Our veterans have my deepest
gratitude and respect.
Today, and every day we
thank them for their service.
(Armed Forces Medley)
(Armed Forces Medley continues)
(patriotic music)
- To begin I'd like to
thank President Salovey
and Secretary Goff-Crews
for leading the university
and honoring veterans each year.
I also want to thank Dean Sodi,
Patricia Wei and Jack
Beecher, who each play a role
in ensuring the success
of student veterans.
In 2011, I was looking for some excitement
and a way to pay for college.
Convinced I knew what I was doing,
I enlisted in the Marine Corps.
After working on unmanned aircraft
and serving as a Marine security guard
at Embassies and Consulates,
I decided to earn a degree
at an officer's commission
through the Marine Corps
Enlisted to Officer Program.
In 2017, after being accepted
to Yale's Eli Whitney students Program,
I moved to Connecticut
to begin my assignment
as a full-time undergraduate.
After settling in, I couldn't
wait to meet my neighbors.
I was especially curious about Maryann,
who lives three doors down.
Maryann is 92 years old,
and she spends most of
her days pulling weeds
and trimming flowers in the garden.
Before COVID-19, she went to
the gym three times a week.
When her gym decided to close in March,
she was outraged and told me
that she just didn't know
how she would stay in shape.
Maryann and I don't seem
to have much in common.
She was born in 1928 and was 90 years
before all military jobs opened to women.
She attended New Haven's
Hillhouse High School,
where she learned how to cook and sew.
Despite the many differences in decades
between Maryann and me, we
do have one thing in common.
Her husband, George was a Marine.
Also a New Havener,
George was born in 1923
and was Commercial High
School's star basketball player.
When Maryann showed me his team picture,
she wanted me to know that
despite being the shortest
on the team, he was their best player.
Like many in his generation,
he enlisted soon after graduating in 1941.
George would go on to fight two
of the War's most historic battles.
At Iwo Jima where Marines
and a Navy corpsman raised
the flag on Mount Suribachi
and on Okinawa, the bloodiest
battle of the Pacific War.
Maryann has told me
that George never talked
to her about the war,
but that he was a Marine
through and through.
That he loved his country, his family,
and that he was proud to have served.
He was outgoing and in Maryann’s words,
he had a lot of parties.
She told me that if he were alive today,
he would have had some
great stories to tell me,
but that he never exaggerated.
To be fair, I don't think
there'd be much room
for embellishment.
After returning from the war,
he met Maryann at Franklin
Street's Falcon Dance Hall,
on Valentines Day 1946.
They were married the next year,
settled into civilian life,
and eventually moved to the
street we live on today.
When George was in his 50s,
he enrolled at the University of New Haven
and earned a degree in business.
Maryann was very proud when she told me
that this degree usually took four years,
but that George did it in two.
I laughed when she said this,
thinking about Zach Metcalf, Marine,
and Timothy Dwight, class of 2018,
who also did it in two.
George and Maryann were
married for 70 years.
What I've learned from Maryann,
besides how great life can be at 92,
is that the pride that comes with service
is not only felt by us.
It's also felt by our families.
This is part of the reason we celebrate.
Veterans Day is for those who have served.
And it's for Maryann, for
people like my own parents.
And for many of you listening
today who admire the service
and sacrifice of someone close to you.
I'm reminded of this each time
Maryann asked me about my
experiences in the Marine Corps
or invites me inside to
show me pictures of George.
I'm also reminded of this
when the Naval ROTC midshipman
and I gather on the steps
of Sterling Memorial Library
and campus visitors stopped to tell us
about their son or
daughter who was serving,
or their own stories from
the Navy or the Marine Corps.
I think this message is
especially fitting this year,
when although we can't gather together
to celebrate students, faculty, staff,
and alumni, we're joined
virtually by more friends
and family than probably ever before.
So to all veterans past,
present and future,
thank you for your service
and your sacrifice,
and happy Veteran's Day.
(trumpets playing Taps)
- Our loving and merciful God
of many names and all generations.
We are thankful beyond measure
for the courage, commitment,
and sacrifices of our veterans
who have served bravely and selflessly
in the United States Armed
Forces on land, sea, or sky.
The legacy of their service to our country
and to our world is one that
must never be forgotten.
We remember with deep respect
and unending gratitude,
those who have lost their
lives in this service.
we are forever in their debt
and we honor their families whose loss
can never really be made whole.
Gracious God, we also
ask for continued healing
for all those who struggle
with the visible and
invisible scars of war.
We asked special regard
for those who have served,
but who have not been
found and returned home.
And for those who have returned,
but who have yet to
find themselves at home.
We hold close in our hearts
those who are currently deployed
and ask that your gentle
hand watch over them
and guide them safely
back to their loved ones.
May we never forget all that
our many veterans have done
to protect freedom and human rights.
As we work to realize
the kind of world You,
our loving God intends for us,
may we continue to seek peace.
Peace born from wisdom and understanding,
nurtured with compassion and mercy,
strengthened by courage and commitment.
For this we say, Amen.
(patriotic music)
(flag flapping)